sur la place publique denis procès
ukrainien charge des caisses de
bouteilles destinées à la défense de
leur ville
ce sont des cocktails molotov à quoi ça
va servir c'est la seule façon possible
de protéger nos enfants nos mères nos
pères et nos grands parents tout le
monde de ce qui est en train de se
passer
à quelques kilomètres de là devant un
site militaire sensible
[Musique]
des volontaires engagé dans les forces
armées ukrainiennes se prépare au cas où
l'ennemi tenterez de prendre la ville
ces hommes ont choisi de tout quitter
pour défendre leur pays avant le conflit
il était agent de sécurité entrepreneurs
une existence très éloigné d'une vie
militaire
je sais que maintenant je suis plus un
simple physiothérapeute ou un docteur je
suis un soldat dont le but est de viser
l'ennemi avec sa kalachnikov nous
détruirons ans les nuits je suis prêt et
mes enfants et ma femme sont aussi près
des renforts bienvenus en temps de
guerre mais qu'il faut pouvoir équiper
on nous a donné des armes mais nous
n'avons pas assez de gilet pare balles
ni à sept casques
nous demandons à nos partenaires
américains et européens de nous aider
dans ce centre il n'y a pas
d'équipements militaires mais les
habitants tout âge confondu veulent
t'aider leur pays
à l'intérieur c'est une fourmilière
tout le monde vient apporter de la
nourriture des vêtements
tout ce qui pourra être utile à ceux qui
combattent à travers le pays
nous sommes prêts la russie ne
s'attendait pas à ce que notre nation se
saoulent aide si rapidement et agisse si
rapidement les gens ordinaires les
acteurs les chanteurs les réalisateurs
ont quitté leur famille pour rejoindre
la défense territoriale
[Musique]
il ya eu ces dernières heures des
avancées les troupes russes dans le sud
et les habitants de dnipro ici se
demande si cette ville stratégique d'un
point de vue militaire sera l'une des
prochaines cibles de l'armée russe en
attendant quel que soit le scénario
qu'ils soient simples civils ou
militaires tout le monde ici est bien
décidé à rester et surtout comme ils le
disent à résister lorsque ce sera
nécessaire